-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Some of my favorite
#WhyDidISayThat
tweets from you guys.
This first one's
from @brigettecwarren.
She says...
"Uh, thank -- thank you."
-"I will."
-This next one's
from @angelsteve89.
-Aww.
-He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That makes sense.
-"I thought this was a hobby."
-This one's from @chelsey-alese.
She said...
-AJ.
-"I thought the 'J' was silent."
-[ Chuckling ]
A-Y J-A-Y.
-This one's from @BaysSiegers.
She said...
Crazy how stairs work.
-Technology.
-Thank you.
-Thanks, chief.
-This one's from...
This is funny.
It's from @DougWalsh1.
He said...
-Ohh!
[ Audience ohh's ]
Mistake! Ohh!
-[ Laughing ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Mood killer right there.
-Ooh, he should not
have uddered that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No!
There he is. Retiring.
Steve Higgins, everybody.
♪♪♪♪
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Oh, he's back.
You're back.
-Oh, yeah, I'm back.
-You're back already?
-Everybody was in a bad moo'd.
[ Scattered laughter ]
[ Band plays ]
-Bad...
♪♪♪♪
-Whoa.
-Man, hey, buddy, welcome back
-It's tough.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's rough out there.
Can't hide.
Nowhere to hide.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Oh, God.
Wait, are you on a --
[ Both chuckling ]
-I milked that
for all it was worth.
-I know you did.
No, no, no, no. Stop.
♪♪♪♪
-It's Thursday!
-I know it is.
-You know, it's America.
-I know it.
This one's from @WantPeace4All
-Aww.
-She says...
[ Applause ]
"Do you think I'm cute?"
-"Here you go."
[ Both chuckling ]
"You wish."
-This one's from @Koopgirl
She says...
-Oy! Oy!
[ Audience ooh's ]
Hey, ho!
[ Band plays funky music ]
Oh!
-This one is from @Hrbngr.
He says...
When is this going to end?
-"You're not hired."
-This one's from @DRock0708.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
"I was being honest."
-Yeah, "I'm being honest."
-[ Laughs ]
-"It's my fault." [ Laughs ]
-"Because I'm a jerk?"
Alright, cool. Alright man
Take care.
-This one is from...
Oh, this is great.
He's a teacher.
It's from @BenHerrick727.
He says...
-Oy!
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh!
[ Chuckling ] Oh!
-Cover your "A" holes.
[ Both laugh ]
-This last one is cute.
This is from @CheVersacee.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it. Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#WeddingFails from you guys.
This first one is
from @JWiederspan.
-Yeah.
-She says...
-Oh! Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
That is awful.
-Oh, my God.
-That is a nightmare.
"This song's a little bit
out of my range,
but I'm gonna try it, anyway."
[ Voice cracking ]
♪♪ All by myself ♪♪
-Father and daughter dance
-I remember one time
at a wedding --
My friend Rob and Denise,
family friends,
we went to his wedding.
My mom
always would get
in trouble wherever we went.
She was just a magnet
for making trouble.
And she kind of had like
bad knees or something,
so she kind of walked a little
bit kind of like Ozzy Osbourne
We went to this wedding,
and we're at the reception
They're about to announce
the wedding party,
you know, and then, the brid
and groom. Mom goes --
[ As Gloria ]
I got to go to the bathroom.
I go, "Don't do it now.
Why would you do it now?
Wait till they
introduce everybody.
Just hold it for 10 minute
and then go." She goes --
[ As Gloria ]
I got to go now.
I go, "God.
Alright, just do it quick
because they haven't
introduced."
She goes, "Okay."
So she's walking to the bathroom
and I'm like, "Ah, man,
there's no way
she's gonna make it.
She's in there,
and me and my dad
are waiting for her to come out,
and all of a sudden they started
putting a smoke machine.
So, this is a nightmare
for my mother.
This is like she's gonna
come out of the bathroom like,
"What happened?"
So, smoke machine,
laser beams, like --
[ As deejay ]
Alright, everybody,
put your hands together.
We're gonna get
this party started.
Give it up for the bridesmaid!
Give it up for he best man!"
And then they go,
"Here they are,
the husband and wife,
Robert and Denise Daniel,"
and my mom comes walking
through the fog.
[ As Gloria ] What in the --
I'm like, "Gloria! Mom!
Get over here!"
-[ Laughing ]
-Unbelievable person.
-"The toilet broke."
-She had like no idea
where she was,
like, "What is happening?"
Laser beams.
Alright, this one is
from @yourbizsucks.
-Ooh, wow.
-Wow.
-He says...
-Oh, snap!
-"He was not happy."
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-I think that's funny.
-Round two.
Three's a charm.
-This one is
from @Patrick-Neville.
He says...
Look at this photo.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-Oh, my God.
-In shock. He's like --
-A ghost?!
-Wow.
This one's from @sdsmith987.
She says...
-Oh!
-Wow.
Strong move on the
mother-in-law.
Strong move.
-"That they would like."
-Yeah.
"This is something we like."
-"We like to eat food we like.
I mean, you can eat
your garbage food."
-This one's from @lifealertme.
He says...
Look at the photo.
-Wow! Oh!
-Wow!
I hope that...
[ Laughs ]
...that was underwear we saw
-Yeah, yeah.
-This one's from @Beer-Stat.
He says...
[ Laughing ]
-[ Moos, laughs ]
-Well, the beauty of nature.
-[ Both shouting as cow ]
-Do you take --
[ Loud groaning moo ]
-Ohh, God!
-"Push, Bessy, push!"
[ Lows ]
-"Push, Bessy." Oh, my God
[ Laughing ]
-[ Loud groaning moo ]
-Thank goodness
we did those Lamaze classes.
This one's from @aacampisi
She says...
Look at this.
-Oh!
[ Rimshot ]
-I love the claps in there
"In the exact same dress!"
[ Both laugh ]
That's pretty classic.
This one's called @IamIshIsh1.
She says...
-Oh. Oh!
-A fish head.
-A fish head. Oh, God.
-Oh, my God.
-This one is classic.
This one's from @AmyPennza
She says...
Look at this.
She wore a wedding dress!
-Oh!
-Come on!
-Come on! Come on!
That is unbelievable!
There you have it. Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-So now I thought I'd shar
some of my favorite
#MyWeirdSecret tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's
from @ratchel78.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Aw.
-"It's not you, shampoo.
It's me."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @lindsspace.
She says...
-Ohh...
-That's very nice.
That's thoughtful.
-It's sweet.
-That's right. You never know.
-That's just sweet.
-That's very nice.
This one's from @simontobey.
He says...
That happens to me all the time.
I'd leave Barnes & Noble,
They got those giant securit
wall things.
And I'm just leaving.
I'm like,
"Did I --
I didn't steal anything."
Of course, I did, but...
just a couple Nooks.
[ Laughter ]
This one's
from @marie-[cunicella]
"koo-zee-nella"?
Oh, "koo-ni-sella."
I apologize. She says...
"We're just gonna
let this simmer, right here.
And come over here. We're
gonna make a little --
my secret is a little lemo
in there."
I do that, too.
Oh, this is great.
This one's from @Penswild87.
She says...
[ Awwing ]
I do that with beer,
so don't worry about it.
It's fine.
This one's from @EBelindaKeaton.
She says...
That's a life hack,
right there.
That's fantastic.
I'm going to steal that.
-Yeah.
Then, you can also pretend lik
you're being broken up wit
in a movie.
-That's true.
This one's from @jenball10
She says...
[ Laughter ]
I mean, why not?
They're real families.
-Yeah, come on. They're
real families.
-Survey says, "That's creepy."
Survey says,
"That's creepy."
I would like that.
See some family photos of them
-Yeah.
-This one's from @asencio-ryan
He says...
[ Laughter ]
"You have high cholesterol."
"I'd like to order
three more pizzas."
This one's from @richandcorey.
He says...
That's sad.
That is just sad.
This last one, here, is
from @Stephy-steph25.
She says...
I got you, there.
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...